ce matin là comme chaque matin aux
enfants partait jouer
derrière dans la forêt
quelle belle journée à mon pic et pic et
collègues un bourg et bouira tatum am
stram gram
à
pourtant ils n'avaient pas le coeur à
jouer si bien qu'au bout d'un certain
temps ils décidèrent de rentrer chez eux
quand soudain
etc etc etc etc
c'était le début de rejouer ses débuts
de rejouer vous allez donner au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 5 et 6
et 7 novembre prochains
rejouer ce à double sens au fond 1 c'est
le jouer de la musique jouer jouer c'est
le jeu d'enfant puisque c'est aussi des
souvenirs d'enfance
on joue on joue on rejoue mais il a
beaucoup hésité la première fois je
voulais l'appeler jouer tout simplement
un ensuite rejoué ou de ses venues et
ensuite jouer et rejouer etc jusqu'à
l'appeler rejouer avec l'idée d'avoir eu
un grand air et jouer à l'intérieur du
mot avec un grand j enfin tout se joue
il se rejoue et comptait fait là-dessus
et aussi bien dans la musique que dans
notre vie c'est en tout cas ce que je
veux essayer de faire comprendre dans le
rapport direct avec les enfants c'est
que vos enfants puisque c'est toujours à
jouer ouais mais mais justement enfin
c'est à la fois un jeu musical c'est à
la fois un cours et c'est à la fois vous
souvenir d'enfance non oui c'est une un
conte qui devient mon histoire pas le
contraire c est en fait qu il devient
mon histoire sans que ça soit explicite
non les enfants c'est pas les
radiographies n'ont surtout pas du tout
mais étant donné que je commence par
faire 30 minutes sur de musique avec une
tresse pièce sur un compte que j'ai
d'hoffmann qu'il part d'un conte
d'hoffmann mais que j'ai totalement
réécrit et sertis à l'intérieur de la
musique
ce qui m'intéressait puisqu'il s'agit
d'eux
musique narrative il s'agit de musique
et de mots et que je suis content heures
dans cette histoire compteur dans cette
histoire il m'intéressait de rejouer
après intégralement c'est ma musique
avec d'autres mots les mêmes histoires
différentes avec une soeur différentes
la mienne et se trouve que c'est ce que
je pense et que fectivement le rapport
de la musique avec le mot est quelque
chose qui passe par l'imagination et qui
passent pas du tout par la vérité la
preuve
ceci n'est pas été dit voyez pas une
musique qui se fait pour le travail qui
est fait par la comédie c'est
l'expérience qu'on a de cette muse un
kiki qui donnent le mot donc voilà ce
qui m'intéresse maintenant sur compte
oui et ça m'intéresse de voir dans
quelle mesure pour eux il n'y a pas une
forme de trahison c'est à dire mais il
nous avait dit ça avec cette musique et
maintenant il nous dit autre chose avec
cette même musique nous at il menti deux
fois ou dit la vérité une seule fois et
laquelle je pense que tout est possible
comme réaction face à ça mais ça
m'intéresse de les mettre devant quelque
chose qui libère la musique finalement
de la vérité oui mais pas de vérité de
la musique ou non on lui donne enfin
sauf la vérité ou au présent de ce conte
ce qu'on rencontre et espère précisément
la vérité dans laquelle je suis au
moment où je me sens pour moi ce qui
impulse le mot c'est ce que je joue au
moment je joue quand vous parlez de
votre force pour mettre la musique trop
fort c'est votre petite enfance et c'est
mon enfance musicale essentiellement
c'est à dire que
ce que j'essaie de comprendre dans cette
dans cette histoire il leur faire
comprendre c'est ce qui amène un enfant
à devenir compositeur aussi bête que ça
c'est je suis effrayé souvent de voir
parce qu'il ya aucune raison de voir des
enfants aujourd'hui tous les enfants qui
sont là sont potentiellement des
compositeurs en herbe je sais pas en
tout cas il ya une certainement une
histoire particulière avec la création
qui se joue qui se jouait pas par la
musique qui se joue par d'autres choses
mais sa part quand même deux à un moment
la décision d'observer d'entendre ou
deux euros de ne pas être contentes
quelque chose c'est à dire j'entends une
sirène de police non là je me fiche un
peu
si moi j'entendais la sirène de police
j'entendais réellement quelque chose qui
était des notes
je commence à elle le fait un peu
harmonisé à l'orchestré et de me dire
mais c'est notre m'intéresse c'est pas
le sort du type qui est ça sera un
écrivain qui ferait un scénario sur qui
vient des wikis vient d'être assassinée
moi je m'en fiche totalement
ç'a vraiment peu importe j'ai pas de
rapport avec ça mon imagination ce n'est
pas là elle cm sur le bruit que ça fait
en train un arbre et la maison en face
parce que dont il y avait une formule
célèbre 68 tout est politique d'eric
tout est musique
pas pour moi pour tout son et vous
parlez là j'entends des notes
le bruissement de votre pull et c'est
pour moi c'est un rythme ça inclut une
tout de suite je l'entends en musique
ternaire par exemple mais ça maintenant
vous êtes vous c'est une déformation
professionnelle ou c'est quelque chose
qui revient à l'enfance justement oui
c'est un enfant se croient que
réellement c'est comme ça que je me suis
alerter des dangers des bonheurs de tout
ce que vous voudrez c'est à dire c'est
comme ça que mon système émotionnel
s'est mis en veille 1 aucun pan veille
au congrès au contraire on éveille en
éveil il s'est mis par le som c'était
une manière pour moi beaucoup plus
direct c'est peut-être là pour le coup
c'est tout simplement la physiologie
wyss et puis surtout je vais ce problème
de l'oreille absolue c'est quand même
oui mais voilà donc on est tombés tous
été des notes alors il ya trois
instruments il ya le piano
cette petite cloche seul gage pour
chapitre lossless de cloche d'hôtel qui
a trouvé sa place et pourquoi la cloche
la première apparition donc dans le
conte peut pas venir du piano elle vient
de quelque chose qui pour moi surnaturel
visible
c'est pas des nues sont invités je
réagis aux usa oui vraiment
c'est quoi cette note en fait si je suis
enfant ici c'est quoi cette note cette
note c'est ça l'état et fa dièse bon
vous dites ces cloches mois jeudi face à
liège ni même fait très on va dire
fakhar d'autant plus est entre les deux
donc quand fossiles au piano et enfin je
dis c'est pas faux c'est un fait faux
faux faux
c'est complètement faux mais c'est même
pas fatigué c'est fort avec un petit peu
fou donc faut déjà ça dit beaucoup sur
la beauté donc comme ça on est là dessus
et je le cherche
ce matin là après il faut dire comme
chaque matin
mais bon moi chaque chaque quand
j'entends quelqu'un a insisté sur chaque
c'est important que ce soit un premier
temps bon
ce matin là comme chaque mois comme
chaque année c'est ça qui déclenche la
mémoire c'est un travail difficile de
mettre les mots justement je mets en
place et même rythme avec leurs très
difficile très difficile
par exemple là je dois saisir ici le
moment où dans ma tête donc sage et ça
ce matin là comme chaque matin
je prends la cloche à mon compte
d'accord la cloche est devenu du piano
du violon
alors pour moi évidemment au niveau
concentration ça veut dire je joue avec
ce qui reste d'elle les enfants partent
et jouer maintenant et si on écoute bien
derrière
on entre à l'intérieur du son est pour
moi un trait à l'intérieur du son c'est
derrière dans la forêt donc si je vous
dis je
les enfants ont rentré joue derrière
dans la forêt d'une manière déconnecté
de ma tension mois les musiques c'est
vous qui les avez complètement refait
tout presque tout mais toutes celles que
j'ai pas écrite il ya des citations
oui oui beaucoup me tenir quelques jours
mais par contre prenons un exemple
malheur l'a dit j'ai un moment cédé
référence c'est à dire que je me
retrouve dans une situation où je
découvre une pas dans le comtat mais
dans ma vie réelle je découvre une
sa faune et de malheur qui me bouleverse
que je suis devant quelque chose
d'immense nous n'arrive pas même pas
intégré au piano le piano n'est pas
assez grand pour ça donc c'est ça que
j'essaie de là je faisais les notations
pour ça parce que je dis là lassana
intégrait pas par exemple le début de
set je prends la codah la codah du pôle
est vraiment la connaître un coda du
deuxième scherzo de la cinquième de
symphonies de mahler donc voyez c'est je
cite pas ça c'est passage le site mais
je cite quelque chose qui pour moi est
vraiment aussi référencé que ça c'est à
dire comme une chose qui entrait en moi
comme une impossibilité alors ça donne
ça pendant vos débuts de la symphonie
c'est dans ma tête c'était un c'est une
grosse caisse
ça je le savais pas et une grosse caisse
qu'elle ait pas de fréquence donc au
piano ça donc ce qu'on appelle une chose
harmonique et non
à
j'avais que ça comme solution miracle à
ce site la neuvième de malheur de bytom
j'ai pas d'autre solution
parce que ça c'est une timbale et une
timbale par nature c'est un bruit
surprenant qui n'arrive pas dans leur
caisse donc j'ai cassé le pied noz et
avec ça à la disposition et la voilà
c'est qu'il moyen de faire rentrer leurs
caisses trt dans cet instrument
sachant que il doit le faire exploser en
même temps le faire déborder
voilà une citation ça c'est vraiment
itation mais elle ne sert pas à jouer
malheur non mais l'impossibilité de le
jouer ça va expliquer le sentiment que
vous aviez franck avdic bon
malheureusement s'arrête là pour
l'instant je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve qu'on continue cette cette
conversation
je rappelle que vous êtes le 5 6 et 7
novembre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et que le
spectacle s'appelle rejouer